Farmland flattened in the name of
progress
this sprawling construction site the
size of nearly 300 football pitches will
house a large chinese-built electric
vehicle Factory officials in Hungary
hope the 8 billion dollar project will
help the nation become a global hub for
lithium-ion battery Manufacturing
but locals like Eva cosma are
apprehensive
you have this bad feeling when you walk
past the area where they are building I
simply feel this bad feeling in my
stomach is this progress really pouring
concrete over nature while we know how
polluting the factory is going to be is
this the green future for who I'm sure
not for us
[Music]
the Project's announcement came as a
surprise to many here the people living
in the de Breton area weren't consulted
even others have been campaigning
against it their biggest concern is the
water supply
the northeastern region was already
experiencing droughts and shortages they
fear that the water demands of such a
huge Factory could destroy the local
environment
a comprehensive large-scale
environmental assessment would be needed
and its results should be consulted with
Society unfortunately this has not
happened that's why we do not see what
the environmental impacts are
but the government says it's a golden
opportunity for the economy
Chinese Investments have a huge role to
play in keeping the Hungarian economy
growing that's why we will continue to
encourage Chinese investment in Hungary
and we will always give the maximum
possible support to them
some have been organizing rallies
against the project despite knowing
their efforts may not amount to much
news
we have been told that there's nothing
we can do about the factory and it will
be built but deep down we hope it won't
I cannot wake up in the morning knowing
that I am showing my children that
there's nothing we can do here so I say
let's do everything we can
with construction already underway the
factory appears inevitable but still the
people of depression protest
hoping the environmental disaster they
fear can still be averted
Vinton Monahan Al Jazeera